alors évidemment bonjour à tous il est
6h30 du matin vous n'êtes pas très bien
réveiller vous êtes d'un décor de pierre
cros vous fait réveiller par évidemment
bonjour à tous et là vous dites je me
suis planté
c'est sûr je me suis planté pas
forcément parce que au moins de mars
dernier pierre m'avait invité pour faire
une vidéo ensemble et ça m'avait fait
passer le cap des dix mille personnes
qui suivaient mais vidéo et en cette fin
d'année nous renouvelons l'expérience et
ça c'est vraiment cool
alors on l'a fait sur sa chaîne s'est
déjà sorti je vous mets le lien dans la
description et sans vouloir trop vous
disais c'est la première fois que sur
une vidéo je me foire
on peut moi je suis prêt a commencé
alors je suis juste leur expliquer parce
que toi tu sais à peu près les demandes
et pierre cros quelque chose de très
particulier je vais garder les rushs de
ce quelque chose de particulier mais
vous n'allez pas le voir je vais couper
et parce qu'en fait je truc mais vidéo
comme ça au tandem chaussée sauf que
exceptionnellement je mettrai le passage
coupé à la fin de cette vidéo là et vous
serez ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
j'avais ils ont compris c'est pierre
proches
je veux tenir compte des abonnés à 8
soit tu les tiens pleines mains ah ouais
bah écoute des abonnés ça se tient bien
hier beaucoup plus ça concerne beaucoup
sont 165 milliards quand je conduis très
haut mais bientôt 170000 j'allais vite
là mais sont pas très éveillé en moi
j'ai plus l'habitude de les voir à 17
heures on a deux trois mois là tu le
reconnais il y en a deux trois plupart
que si l'on reconnaît donc ça c'est un
fond de jazz
non c'est un parquet comme quoi je ne
connais pas encore les termes techniques
alors qu'hier je vais essayer de trouver
ton mot de passe twitter mais sait-on
mot de passe je vais je te demanderai
confirmation je parle tu vois ce que je
ne peux pas te mettre dans l'embarras
je fais de l'écrire tout comme ça que je
vois en sorte qu'ils le voient pas paris
a longtemps qu'ils le voient pas
longtemps pervers non mais je n'ai
jamais cru possible alors qu'est
patinoire à décor possible mais je
devais marcher confiance écoutons
semaine depuis
après peut-être que eux ils sont très
très bons sur ma chaîne porte-
mentaliser et qui vont nous trouver en
tant que tu vois oui tu leur as appris
les dénégations 1 126 vidéo maintenant
un pied donc si quelqu'un se connecte
n'allez pas voir les messages privés
voilà n'allez pas voir les jeux que tu
peux pas sur tes j'avais et effacer ce
que moi je t'ai envoyé c'est tout les
photos les photos alors première
question mais je te pose une question
d'âge tous demandent une vraie réponse
est ce qu'il ya un mélange de lettres et
de chiffres il ya un mélange de lettres
de chiffres
d'accord est ce que ces mélanges et
aléatoirement ou est ce que ça veut dire
quelque chose à te dire que c'est à dire
quelque chose mort c'est pas par exemple
xr2 dans l'absolu
quelque chose ça veut dire quelque chose
on n'est plus sûr du bishop 21 c'est sa
jambe enfin c'est ça ça commence donc
par les lettres de vue comment je t'ai
vu réfléchir et sa fine par les chiffres
c'est quoi tu m'as vu réfléchir oui est
ce que tu pourrais penser à la première
lettre me regardait aimé et dire stop
mais dans ta tête surtout pas pour de
vrai ok ça c'est bien compris comme
consigne tu dis stop dans ta tête au
moment où jeudi de la première lettre de
ton mot de passe d'accord a b c d e f g
h i j k l mn op qui est resté uv w x y z
ok je pense que j'ai passé la lettre
est-ce que ça c'est quand elle tombe
premières lettres correct je j'ai une
bonne série de vidéos avec pierre cros
moi je peux dire que j'ai bien tu rates
tout ce que tu entends prendre avec moi
mais peut-être j'ai pas bien faire stop
dans ma tête non c'est ça bon écoute dix
mois la première fille tu dis mais la
presse s'était rassemblée âgées hockey
bref vous empressez pas placer au même
endroit j'ai galéré sur la première mais
bon ben voila mais au moins tout le
monde sait que c'est un c alors je vais
mettre quand je te le dis plus heureux
moi je positionne être oui c'est
vraiment quand je fais le tour de
mentalisme je vais essayer de trouver le
nombre de syllabes tu me regarde dans
les yeux
ouais là tu comptes les syllabes dans ta
tête si on a zéro une deux trois quatre
opte l'aca s'est relevé à deux donc on
est à deux c'est correct
tu vas tu veux un
ouais ouais ben en fait je crois qu'il
faut que je te prennent à l'envers si je
peux me permettre
et donc il ya des chiffres après donc ça
peut être
chiffre entre 0 et 9 tu vois ça peut
être un nombre entre 10 et 100 emplois
vous avez vu des yeux tout ronds encore
fait l'arc de cercle donc on est entre
10 et 100 d'accord on pas en train de
chercher une vanne sur rmc pas grave moi
ça me donne des infos je commençais par
le chiffre je sens que ça va mieux
attendre je sais je suis senti super coq
êtes tous allez allez ok ça peut être un
chiffre qui veut rien dire près
complètement au hasard comme ça peut
être quelque chose qui ait du sens comme
69 comme de 51 comme comme le set parce
que c'est magique mais ça c'est pas de
chiffres comme 18 pour les pompiers
comme 15 pour les ambulances comme xiii
qui porte bonheur comme 98 pour la coupe
du monde de football et c'est quelque
chose qui a du sens et je les ai déjà
dit dans le tas c'est quand même de
shakespeare par l'état tu peux me
confirmer que c'est bien le chiffre là
j'ai pas le savoir car c'est ça ou pas
le nombre c'est ça je te connais le
moment je le dis je peux le coupé c'est
ça la ils le sont pas on est amis
wallons on a mis un an à 4 5 ans et
qu'on se connaît où je te fais confiance
se crée alors il faut que je termine de
trouver le mot maintenant mais en deux
syllabes lab126 lab martin puisque sur
dans la faute on peut le voir qu'on me
reprenne sur ma chaîne tu m'as dit que
ça peut avoir dix ans là bas je viens de
la voir
non mais oui je les ai vus direct mais
je vous jure je viens de l'avoir direct
chose explique ray tout à l'heure non je
vous pourrez pas vous l'expliquer du
coup est ce que ton mot de passe c'est
ça
je préviens d'une promesse non mais par
rapport aux photos et tout j'ai tissé
commenge les huiles j'ai levé les yeux
j'ai vu le caennais alors attend les
petites variations quand même ouais un
truc est incorrect ah ben ouais c'est
pas canard 13 non spatial non c'est pas
ça déjà c'est pas ça mais moi j'ai
trouvé avec ce que j'ai marqué qu'à une
minuscule il ya une minuscule je vais
pas inventer un petit tour devant thèse
pour dominer la lettre sur laquelle ils
d'accord alors tu penses à la lettre sur
lequel il ya une minuscule ouais c'est à
peine ard ça bougeait sur le banc quand
même 4 ever ouais c'est ça est-ce que je
peux prendre deux minutes pour aller
face et les deux trois dames que au cas
où il ya des gens qui se connectent pas
par hasard sur mon compte l'un non non
non non non
d'accord tu sais pourquoi personne se
connectera pourquoi parce qu'ils vont
regarder l'eau face et le passage que je
vais leur coupe et je vais essayer donc
de trouver le mot de passe de son compte
twitter mais ça je vais leur annoncer
leur expliquer je n'ai pas donné ton
vrai mot de passe évidemment donc je
vais te demander de changer de mot de
passe dans ta tête tu vois quelqu'un
quel mot de passe tu pourrais mettre sur
twitter là tu changes ton mot de passe
physiquement ou que dans ta tête si tu
veux et sauf que ça ils vont l'apprendre
qu'à la fin durant la vidéo y seront
persuadés d'avoir ton vrai mot de passe
si jamais je le trouve les [ __ ] voilà
ça se sera mis donc à la fin on gagne on
revient au moment où ça prend déjà pas
de faire du buzz
bah ouais c'était très bien dans et même
si ça le mot de passe a été inventé oui
sa g était très fort alors ça c'est un
coup de chance qu'on s'est passé oui
complètement parce que je suis en
général la personne qui cherche je la
regarde exactement où j'avais fait une
vidéo avec le lac d'uby ni où elle
devait l inventaire le nom d'une chanson
et c est en fait c'est souvent à
laâyoune jeune suspecte
j'appelle çà dire que si tu demandes à
quelqu'un de créer quelque chose là pour
faire un truc de mentalisme et bien
comme dans usual suspects tu vas
retrouver les éléments qui l'ont inspiré
autour de lui mais moi j'ai pas vu le
film donc et bas à la fin
non j'ai l'âge de foule ouais c'est
celui-là a cédé parce qu'elle nous à la
base on avait une question avec mes
abonnés commença en question je vous
écoute pas si on voulait savoir où et
comment se passaient le régime écoute
j'ai reçu beaucoup des vidéos et on
trouvait de ça on parlait plus non je le
cache totalement en fait non attends là
des radios donc que j'ai posté vendredi
sur ma chaîne l'angle de la caméra et
qu'on voit le ventre un et j'ai plein de
commentaires de ce genre c'est vrai
ouais du coup j'ai ici je vais je vais
essayer de relancer quelque chose de
fort d'accord c'était d'aller chez mcdo
l'appui on veut parler d'un certain est
que en place mais on trouvait sur toute
l'année quoi t'es pas ils sont pas ils
sont pas l'anti sur cette chaîne
ils sont très gentils et très
bienveillant et si jamais il y en a qui
ont le malheur de ne pas encore
connaître pierre cros là où juste de
connaissances est comme ça mais allez
déjà voir moi me gamme et les sur la
chaîne de pierre on a fait un truc hyper
rigolo et c'est la première fois que je
rate et ben ça ça se voit chez pias est
allé sommes plus en l'air à vous abonner
à aller voir ce qu'on a fait avec piaf
sur sa chaîne et rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao est ce que tu crois qu'il
reste aussi longtemps qu'on dit zhao
j'espère pas sinon ils n'ont pas de vie